jeez I'm just going through it again in
my head how do you get 3 shots off on a
man with 2 guns and why do you bring him
delicious piping hot Arby's right before
you're gonna blow them away how can Juan
don't touch Trudy put it back
the first rule let's go from the top ok
ok hey Rico hey what you doing with my
blow me I went out to get you a
delicious piping hot Arby's roast beef
sandwich and I find out you're doin my
blow while I'm gone
Jim please makes your mouth numb don't
do that for real from the top ok places
ok I'm sorry
oh hey Rico I'm back I'm acting casual
I'm being cool nothing's up nothing's up
at all all I did was go get some
delicious piping hot Arby's I see you're
jacking this in this scenario ok well I
got a delicious beef and cheddar for you
[Music]
ok that's a trajectory it's ok keep on
keep one two three and I thought I'd
bring you a little peace offering some
delicious Arby's go back no no no no no
this never happened oh this never
happened that we know of you go back I'm
Carrie no Rico hi Rico I just got back
with that delicious Arby's you asked me
to get thanks for the Arby's one I'm
playin man check it out check all you
want ok check other places this is
probably what he would do ok don't hey
Trudy Trudy ok ok we get it we gotta
play just fruit de Rico dis fruit de
dollars here pay attention for five
seconds that's not important so you
Oh monkey roll monkey monkey
you got to act out what you thought it
was I know I agree but you didn't do
what at the port that I asked you to do
okay I enjoy it's my little GiftA to you
ok you have a nice time eating Arby's
eating Arby's eating Arby's eating
Arby's monkey roll monkey roll monkey uh
I was gettin to poison not monkey roll
Oh poison and now that I've poisoned you
I'm gonna send a message to all the
other Capo's and jefes and it's gonna go
like this
Bam Bam shoot the man who's already dead
that's it already dead why'd they shoot
him 3 time message to the other jefes
now remember before I put the tape up I
got Arby's you said you're gonna come
here now should leave you some delicious
Arby's on the table cause you want some
more bit too it's cold though you guys
been in here for like 7 hours I don't
have they don't have caller ID oh the
FBI probably has caller ID right I would
think they're calling back right
you